dianna follows me at facebook.com slash
Davey how can someone improve their
credit score when there's no debt you
can't and that's a good thing we need to
understand what a FICO score is a FICO
score has according to Phi cos website
four elements to it a much debt you have
the kind of debt you have how you pay
your debt it's all about debt so your
FICO score or into a guy this weekend he
said no Dave I don't really need your
information I have an 855 Aiko score I'm
doing fine and it wasn't a situation
where I it was a social situation where
I couldn't really laugh at him in his
face so I just nodded and said okay and
walked away because there was no I
didn't have time nor did I have the
footing in this conversation to to
completely expose the ridiculous
thinking that that represents let me
help you with that an 850 FICO score
does not mean you have money it does not
mean you have an income it does not mean
you have wealth all it means is you have
paid hundreds of thousands of dollars in
interest to the bank it's the only
possible way to get an 850 FICO score
you have to have a lot of debt have had
it a long time and have paid it
perfectly and stayed in debt religiously
as a matter of fact you've borrowed
money just to keep your FICO score up to
be at that level now does that make
sense well let's think about it the
number one key to building wealth is
having your income to invest instead of
having committed it to other people
that means gotten into debt when you
don't have any payments you have money
to invest in to be generous with and all
the data points tell us that that is the
fastest way to build wealth all the
research gives us that plus common sense
tells you that
so once we understand that the fastest
way to become wealthy is to be out of
debt and we understand secondarily that
the FICO score is 100% built off of your
relationship with debt if you have a
high fate high FICO score it means
you've been playing kissy-face with the
bank a lot once you understand that the
FICO score is not and I'm good with
money score it's not an I'm wealthy
score it's an I love debt score and I'm
really good at borrowing and paying back
a lot of debt over a long period of time
score which is a stupid way to score
whether you're winning with money so
when the guy goes well I'm doing okay
I've got an 80 50 credit score what he
really meant was I'm pretty stupid I'm
giving the bank a lot of money and I
don't have any likely because the
shortest distance between two points is
a straight line that straight line is
debt free I have my income I can put it
in two investments so my point being my
credit score very proudly is
indeterminable which is the FICO score
people way of saying I have a zero score
why do I have a zero score I have had no
debt no accounts open of any kind for a
very long time if you only will do
business with me or loan me money based
on my FICO score we can't do business I
don't have a FICO score because I don't
borrow money because not being in debt
is the fastest way to become wealthy so
your goal should not be how can I keep
my credit score up how can I build my
credit because building your credit is
I'm gonna borrow money
why so later I have the opportunity to
borrow money why so that I can borrow
more money why so I can stay in debt and
make those towers in the skyline be
owned by somebody else because I gave
them my working life's income you
being ruled over by banks they're
telling you what to do they're managing
your life they've built it into the
culture to the point that people
actually walk around bragging about
their I love debt score what a great job
the banking industry has done teaching
you to be in debt and stay in debt which
is where they make all their money the
credit card is the most marketed product
in the history of the world more money
has been spent selling you credit cards
marketing you credit cards than any
other product in the history of the
world and it worked
you all have one or two or twenty two it
worked
don't you feel stupid don't you feel
manipulated don't you feel used you
should you're a slave the borrower is
slave to the lender
so don't improve your credit score have
a goal of having everything paid off in
every account closed and then somewhere
around six months later your credit
score will be fabulously indeterminable
zero how would I get a house how would I
get a house well two possibilities say
you have to get a mortgage with someone
that doesn't use a credit score to issue
a mortgage which is a mortgage company
who actually knows how to write
mortgages the old-fashioned way it's
called manual underwriting like
churchill mortgage does or you'd have to
save up and pay cash yeah yeah I am
and I live that way I live in an
unrealistic world where I've become
unrealistically wealthy managing money
God's ways it works every time so you
have to be like that young couple I ran
into he was an engineer and she's a
teacher just talk to him the other day
they're young they're making a lot of
money
for a young couple so they're unusual
granted but they were making right
around 100 and they're you know twenty
four years old when they started they
had no dad and they decided they were
not going to borrow money for a house so
they lived in an apartment a garage
apartment out back of a rich old lady's
house he cut the rich old lady's grass
and kept her gutters cleaned out and the
rent was almost free because of that
their friends made fun of them their
parents thought they needed counseling
but they made a hundred and their rent
was two hundred fifty dollars a month in
a nice city in a nice neighborhood but
it's a garage apartment out top of over
the top of a garage out back of a lady's
house it was not it was not fabulous
and you know what they did they saved
almost I mean I think they say provide
that $50,000 a year for four years and
they paid cash for a $200,000 house when
they were 28 but everybody made fun of
them now if you're making by then one
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
a year and you're 28 or 30 years old and
you never have a house payment the rest
of your life do you know how rich you're
gonna be see why you don't need a FICO
score hello are you starting to catch on
to these numbers this is real so don't
improve your FICO score set out
destroy it as quickly as possible by
being 100% debt free with all accounts
closed as soon as you possibly can so
kind of countercultural isn't it though
the Bible says that it says be not
conformed to this world don't be like
everybody else
but be transformed how are you
transformed the renewing of your mind
you need ideas that are different than
everybody else's ideas normal is broke
78% of Americans live paycheck to
paycheck the foreclosure rate is at an
all-time high the bankruptcy rate is at
an all-time high and the number one
cause of divorce in America today is
money fights and money problems do you
want to be normal normal sucks why would
you want to be normal whatever everybody
else is doing you want to do exactly the
opposite don't you otherwise you're
gonna be just like them if you do what
they do you're gonna be just like them
so go run up your FICO score if you want
to be broke your whole life don't worry
about your I love debt score if you want
to be broke your whole life you'll be
broke mathematically it's a proven
freakin fact or you can be different
than everyone else be weird
don't be normal mmm that's what winning
is